take climate change as an example i i
think climate change is happening i
think the evidence shows climate change
is happening i think the majority of it
is caused by human activity
um but i am not of the belief that you
shut down all industry across the world
or tax it out of existence in order to
stop climate change i think human beings
have an unbelievably great ability to
adapt
and to create new products and services
it seems like so much of public life is
rooted in the assumption that human
beings are never going to be able to
create our way out of this one
which is a weird thing to say since
human beings have literally been
creating their way out of problems
for all of human history and that's
really accelerated in the last two to
three hundred years
so now going backwards in time i want to
ask you what thing
or achievement or whatever seemed
impossible to a young ben shapiro 20
year old ben shapiro
but now since you had the courage which
i think is one of your dominant traits
you have an incredible amount of courage
um you went into the impossible and you
did it so what thing in the past would
you tell yourself
have this courage go forward what seems
impossible will become possible
honestly i i think that the one thing
that i would tell myself as a young
person
uh is is i i've never had uh uh i've
never been shy uh so that was never
something i had to advise myself to
shirk
uh with the shyness uh to me it would be
uh have the courage to question your own
assumptions and your own opinions
and don't be quite so sure of what it is
that you're saying there i think that
the data have
have changed my mind on that issue and
take a look at all sides i hope that's
something i've gotten better at
over the course of my career and i hope
that people can you know if you listen
to the show but or if you read my
writings
you can hear me kind of turning over
points before i immediately come to a
conclusion
hey hey welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special we're joined today
by brian keating he's distinguished
professor of physics
brian thanks so much for stopping by i
really appreciate it pleasure and honor
to be here ben
as far as science fiction yeah i'm a
huge sci-fi fan you can explore
both moral issues and technological
issues outside the confines of a lot of
the
dictates that that exist in normal
literature if you're writing in a
theoretical universe as opposed to
you know writing in practical one
[Music]
you